I see how it is I feel react to Game of
Thrones with mr. mr. Greg that's fine
you with me again don't include me for
two years and then finally you mean for
like a little bit in Japan yeah that's
true
[Music]
howdy-doody reject nations John Humphrey
here and with me is Game of Thrones your
Game of Thrones personified welcome to
the channel a big fan hello hello I'm
the Game of Thrones really yeah how do I
win uh you you have to be nude and you
have to have dragons that sounds like
Game of Thrones to me yes we are going
to check out a new video from all-time
ten good folks over there subscribe to
all time ten this is Terry chill Rachael
hey man you I let you commit to that and
now your game throw me forever get ready
that's a responsibility people are going
to be debating you for the end of time
Rachel Jackson low she's got comic a
webcomic called angry max fury street I
have never seen Mad Max fury road so I
made a comic about what I think Mad Max
fury road is about and it's about
somebody named angry max and he's so
angry and his friend happy Henry takes
him on a road trip that's the answer I
was looking for this is called ten Game
of Thrones theories that will blow your
mind and if my mind is not blown by the
end of this I would like my money back
this is going to be fun HBO's greatest
or God is like a tight angle and
complicated series out there as a result
it sounds a pulsing - an outlandish
theory or - from the ideas as a whole
show those are warming metaphor so even
we the thought that beerus could be a
mermaid so close was highly artistically
how max fairly soon we thought we'd give
you a rundown of some of the best fan
theories for how will eventually end but
beware the night is dark and full of
spoilers that's why my side yeah
this is why learning sperms theories
that will blow your mind
[Music]
number 10 the faceless men Terry some
Gaiman throws there is you'd love to see
come true and others you really really
wouldn't once there is a fools into the
police Ludlow category is one
surrounding popular fan favorite Arya
Stark
namely it's that only is dead Theory
burned in the season six episode eight
showdown of Jacqueline's prodigies it
was actually the weight loss Aria for
most victorious I think about it
it looks specifically see the weight
dying which has been Game of Thrones
code for that characters already dead in
the past the orders are definitely
against the youngest go in that fight
she had been stabbed multiple times in
the stomach and again bested the weight
before then there was Jacqueline's
reaction why would he give that creepy
little smile unless in you little
something else going on so secretly
wearing arias face the weight is now
traveling up north who knows what her
end game is or I'm going to get is not
good news for Starks King Robert's and
the Lannisters considered using faceless
men assassins to kill Daenerys way back
when meaning it's not out of the
question that the web could be working
for them now
I've to kill Circe's enemies in the
north number nine Samwell is the
narrator this series while it's
beginning a lot of popularity online
lately it even be discussed by John
Bradley the actor who plays the
character in question the idea is that
the entirety of the showed is based on
the quantum events written by everyone's
favorite lace during training Samwell
Tarly and P in 7c family were the
elements at the Citadel surrounded by
books and studying under Professor
Slughorn elite art space red rose rose
is writing history titles with
chronicles of the wars following the
death of King Robert the first time
familiar yet that's basic - just a fancy
way of saying the Prophet going through
some comments on the title saying that
he will god for something a bit more
poetic who can he be thinking of so of
Ice and Fire
perhaps contractures very ridiculous I
fancied a nice even evil we sound
closing the big book of the series
whilst this prediction doesn't really
tell essentially about who will end up
on the Iron Throne
it would be the least Sam survives to
the end the great who is azor Ahai this
theory surrounds a prophecy of legendary
then what sense of war from darkness as
a
I will be born again they'll be born
amid smoke and salt and shall draw light
from the fire a burning sword
Lightbringer very obviously the two most
popular candidates for the role of John
and Daenerys largely because of John's
kick are swordmanship and Daenerys being
born at the height of the storm there
are a thousand of one vlogs explaining
why either of these suit appears also
instead we're going to focus on another
candidate could be a lot more of a curve
point to hound
the moon comes in two defining moments
when sand or clay gauge life the fire
that burned up as a child they can smoke
and the Battle of Blackwater that almost
killed them
aka salt plus it'll be a hell of a plot
to us to see the hounds who's normally
for water buys verifier saving the day
with a flavored salt you can't say that
wouldn't be an amazing and economical
number seven married a man queen we all
know about Mad King Aerys Targaryen but
could we be about to see the mad Queen
for a while there it was thought that
Daenerys is going to fill that role or
with her being the Mad King sort out and
her literally burning her enemies with
dragon fire well now there's a new crew
psycho bidding for the title Cersei the
Lannister name Caracas load up load plot
the King's Landing and executed one of
the most sadistic death of the whole
series which became her throat is really
saying something if we assume this
theory is right and says he is the man
Queen what does this mean for the end of
Thrones
well the Mad King got killed by the
Kingslayer so cemetary sake could the
same theta leave them at Gamla cut the
idea that James confessing is one that's
been looking around for a while it's
based on the prediction of Maggy the
Frog who in the books told the young
Queen that you'll be killed by the Baron
clock which translates as little brother
it's could refer to Tyrion seeing as
that this latitudinal inserting a
Spartan secretly from foreign plot twist
Jane flasch
at number six the war crisscross the
wall the 200 meter tall wall that
stretches along the northern border of
the Seven Kingdoms was allegedly
constructed about eight thousand years
before the events of Thrones the
children of the forest added an
assortment to prevent the White Walkers
crossing it but could everyone's
favorite what device have already broken
that spell basically giving all of
Westeros yes of course which will give
out Brandon Stark in season 6 XO five
what brands do dispose of unsupervised
three at ribboning it was touched and
marked by the night's king this marker
now the White Walkers Road
to these magical defenses and attack
them Branko moving to the heartbreaking
called the door scene now that brans
back in Winterfell
does this things just keep to the
walkers free pass over your room this
leads into another multi render throws
Theory the White Walkers Lin and
everyone else dies the land of oolacile
rule there are hundreds of thousands of
White Walkers and they're super hard to
destroy with George RR Martin's previous
notes of writing for killing our fan
favorites it wouldn't be totally
unfitting then just kill afford the
remaining living character than the
fight ran the building while we're on
the topic of RAM there are a lot of
theories floating around about the role
he has to play in shaping the entire
closet beside even before you started
walking away little Brown was the first
governor to set key events in motion if
you hadn't spied on the Lannister
princess for any Wooden's and push them
up in its how unlucky what happens in
having been one might not have done but
that one grabs a rolling animal control
and timey wimey superpower that makes
the potential for Brandon through it's
even greater it's been confirm that
brain cannot only witness but can
influence notice in the past tense the
whole mobile this is active the
circulation of the bran the Builder
Theory
primer builders who are grinders named
after was the one who built Winterfell
and the devil in the first place the
idea is that modern-day Graham having
seen the devastation of others will
bring travels back in time to pick from
its namesake the reward to defend
against and Bri Anthony after no I'm not
Arian vicious and potentially liver and
brain to make exact an attorney they're
looking less focused on this moment
brainless it was another answer in for
Brandon Cumbria number four I heard
these are the good guys
it has been an absolutely huge plot
twist if it turned out what we should
have been rooting for the walkers all
along but that's one theory that's
actually getting quite a lot of momentum
online of course missile armory know
exactly why they online I think here is
the last ride has become corrupt and
evil and what gives presentation room in
order to justify this the show Spencer
the six years show most of its character
scheming lying murdering hosts raping
and just in many updates another tickle
knuckle remember to subdue it was
actually then we got the warden the
first
think about the mall was allegedly built
as part of the original Azeroth ice
battle to drive the walkers away but
only really truly but it was real quick
enough to hold to devastate to involve
the army even with the children's magic
surely such a thing would have taken
hundreds of years so this leads them to
believe that the mayor in a little time
and I had recently proved it in order to
anymore you can find at night I decided
to some big animal
the walkers with decided tried by Jo
forestry numbers weak three-headed
dragon this theory is one of the most
looking at Game of Thrones series out
there and it's then from a prophecy
given to Daenerys in the book they're a
joke dragon any energetic been
understood pretty much universally to
mean the SEBI Dragon Riders are required
in order to have war citizen knows has
three dragons champions that should be
one of those riders I'm a question I
know it's all be joining her ever since
the infamous office Le Creuset theory
was confirmed in season six the
probability that the second dragon
riding with each on snow has grown but
John might have been the early character
of the secret all carry heritage as a
strong candidate for the third rider is
none other than Tyrion Lannister I'm
[ __ ] Patriot the Macan Aries had
enough and with tokens are now wife
Johanna and Tyrion was the result of
this bet now they probably chose to stay
too watery as further evidence towards
this o authority killed is why using
some of meaning and design a threat
maybe that was more literal than it
first appears
number two the greyscale water fear in
you can't deny there's something
connecting greyscale and the one
difference let's start with some pretty
basic links they certainly are similar
aesthetics and they're both pretty much
zombies amid fear only the fascism item
every scale aka snowmen are said to live
in the rooms of the malaria glitcher the
very home of valerian still one of the
few known substances that can kill a
worker now what this means isn't super
obvious but it inference
accidental coincidences or a rarity
dragon loss another way to kill the dead
has also been treated as a possible cure
of the bracelet and thanks to one of the
grossest eaten through its history we
knows the condition could be cured even
in its advanced stages with similar
traits and weaknesses is it possible
that greyscale is just another
manifestation of the magical hiring the
walkers Christmas stone then just the
waters creature from the living rather
than
after all these don't know where the
infection came from in the first place
only that it passes through physical
contacts
so maybe the night instead army isn't
the only zombie horde that should be
worrying the people of Westeros we might
also be able to control the stone men
number one John and the night kick a
badass warrior based in the North who
once died and a since been reanimated am
i talking about Jon Snow the liking or
both welcome to this theory the grand
finale will see the former become the
latter when discussing the eventual
conclusion of this story your diorama to
describe the finale as bittersweet this
implies that the quiff close to
ultimately triumphs but the costs this
revelation of course sent fans into a
frenzy hypothesizing what the cost could
be one of these candidate would be the
Whigs club whilst and professional
running no earth Jon Snow
a popular prediction is that jungle
sacrificed himself in order to kill the
night king and stop the attack on the
living but to character our hero would
die complete is that you'll become a
selling white will cut like mention
stark and rule the walkers as the new
light king so long as he isn't really
converted to walk up you would then be
able to use his leadership to turn the
advance of the walkers around protecting
the citizens of Westeros how's that for
bittersweet
so that was 10k with race Theory double
border about and you see the show lens
I lost my mind's blown yeah I mean
there's certainly some interesting
theories for sure alright so you know
six degrees of Kevin Bacon
yes ma'am well I feel like there is two
degrees of every game of Thrones care
driver so the number of potential
theories out there are endless yeah and
I feel later for some some series will
come true but people are like oh look at
this coincidence that george RR martin
put in and it's just like every
coincident like there's that you could
say that about everything all of the
characters are somehow intertwined and
not all of them will come true not by a
long shot
I would imagine so I feel like a lot of
fat falls into this category are you in
bed what do you think um I don't love
that theory but I I could see it being
plausible if they wanted to pull that
off sure if the wave was wearing or his
face I wouldn't be thrilled to have that
come true because I like aria
this is my I think it won't come true
face I don't think it'll come true
because george RR martin promised his
wife that he would not kill off aria
because aria is George RR Martin's wife
fit rounder
however the creators of the TV show are
not married to George RR Martin's wife
through that unless they open up like a
polyamorous relationships I never know
unless they're on the Dornish cookie I
am the same being the narrator thing I
mean I died I can totally see that
happening hunter person I feel like I
don't know % happening because george RR
martin is sam yeah basically i mean
they're not many things that are just
nice about Game of Thrones I feel like
that would be nice yes yeah sans telling
the story that makes sense yeah who is
hora hi it's the chosen one for Game of
Thrones do you think it's the Hound
do you think it's John do you think it's
Daenerys do you think it's Tyrion
Lannister do you think it was Spanish
the whole time probably not Olivia
really depressing to it and the why we
are on the show I feel like we've built
so much on top of this John and Daenerys
thing like it would be kind of an odd
thing to do to just left turn and belay
its the Hound but I do think it would be
neat I think it's John I think sudden
gear shift its the Hound that's a little
to Neville Longbottom for me does Jamie
kill Cersei the answer is I feel like
yeah yeah yeah I think that that happens
what you went feeling you want Tyrion to
do it I guess but like I don't know just
like every time Jaime and Cersei have a
scene together I feel like we linger on
Jaime for just a few extra seconds to
watch the reality sinks a little deeper
into his face yeah that theory is pretty
obvious
honestly like I I do think Cersei is a
man Queen and I do think Jaime will kill
Cersei
so when brand makes contact with night
Kings that just break the enchantment of
the wall command Knight king set foot
inside I feel like the walkers
eventually cross the wall they have to
because that's look that's what's going
to happen if it brands fault who cares
they're going to come the end next see
is brand builder brand the builders
oh that one kind of bent my
mind a little bit in a way that I didn't
love much no I didn't bend my mind at
all it made me kind of angry because
number 1 that means bran has no reason
to be named brand bran could be named a
pooh-bah it could be proved on build
like it's just like who's brand named
actor if it's himself if he just in a
perpetual time loop or he just keeps
being named after somebody named bran
where did bran come from where were at
what point did that's that's one of
those fine lines theory things that just
starts to make my head hurt after all
I'm like okay how did you get the first
time having to do that being named
Grantham and if you found a way back in
time like how did you make sure that
your folks named you that like Jude and
also ranked and time-travel and he can
warg
so brain could be anybody bran could
have warned into little finger forever
ago this plotline specifically is the
reason I feel like I need to rewatch the
show at some point I don't love that
theory so much do the walkers win I
don't think it'll be that bleak no
george RR martin said that the ending
would be bittersweet that would be just
bitter fair enough moving on next one to
john Daenerys and Tyrion all Targaryen
I'm John is well John that was revealed
that's pretty that's confirmed they flip
that detail into the point where people
got like upset that we didn't like flip
visibly when that piece of information
came out but yet you're into the looking
blunder lately but that's about the only
clue toward that I don't think he is
they're saying that Tywin hates him and
it's like notes Tywin could also hate
him because Tyrion was a dwarf and
Tyrion killed his wife when he was born
yeah I kind of agree with you I think
the Targaryen might be someone else but
I'm not sure it's tyrion tyrion i just
feel like that would be too convenient
at that point well here are three of the
show's most central and popular
characters who have gone through such
change over time and they're all gonna
like what is it Targaryen now one is
twist Targaryen and have another twist
Targaryen and have that be one of your
favorite characters like seems like a
tall order I don't know how to phrase
this exactly without an associate game
of thrones with that level of like
fanservice almost yeah I want the Hound
to be the last Targaryen that would be
cool exactly who's not actually related
to the mountain
yeah only half related to it when he's
like out some good I mean that seems to
come out here and there through his
characters especially in the are keys
are going through I'll be alright
okay with him being a Targaryen I'm not
okay with him being as or a hi that's a
little bit is white Walker is sandstone
man are they related or are zombies just
popular and nobody cares and let's throw
in more zombies so that we can get some
of the people who watch The Walking Dead
I think that's a cool theory we theory
the whole idea that you know like it's a
similar type of enchantment and it just
depends on whether you were dead or
alive when you came down with it and
that could be one of those you know epic
that part is interesting they love to
stack those odds of especially heading
towards the end of season one battles
are bred to break out and you can know
that nothing would be more gut-wrenching
than noticing that the White Walkers
also have some friends showing up you
know I get you on the zombie part but at
the same sigh I think it's a cool theory
calm down there is also the dragon glass
and Valyrian steel argument but there
are two things in the Game of Thrones
universe that destroy everything and
make everything better
and this Valyrian steel and dragon glass
so like I mean you don't point to
anything and you'll eventually get two
Valyrian steel and dragon glass
I want a sword made of Valyrian steel
Cody's in dragonglass yeah that smells
like every magical thing in Game of
Thrones except for wildfire next milk of
the poppy
nobody wants milk of the box
hey baby dream why I want one scene
where someone just like oh thank you yes
please I needed this ah John becomes a
night king at the end oh I can see it I
can see it especially the way they spun
it in this video that's sort of like
ultimate sacrifice Westeros is just a
weed the army of the night that way yeah
I mean that wasn't where new kind of it
azor Ahai sort of a chosen one who saves
everybody in an unpredictable way great
caller said I was a mightier single tear
coming down my cheek I could see it
happening that one I'm not counting too
much on any happy endings for anybody's
gonna show like they said we're going
for a bittersweet ending I feel like
that's pretty bittersweet you know you
just want stuff to work out for John
John reminds me of Ned and Ned was like
watching all season one I was like oh
yeah this guy knows good
this guy knows - just for the world but
you can't I almost feel like with John
it's one of the like no good deed goes
unpunished and even if you are the
chosen one even if you can save the
realm it's gonna come at a cost John are
you yeah are you the chosen yep
I know nothing you know nothing John
Humphrey that's right that's what they
tell me in the comment box every video
we're talking about you don't know
anything that's my impression of the
Internet the entry well thanks for
checking out this video guys what do you
think which series did you agree with
which ones do you think are nonsense hit
up that comment box and watch Game of
Thrones name is the most [ __ ] yeah
throw out a difference you could
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is out check
out Rachel Jackson on the internet check
out angry max free Street it's gonna be
right here going to put all the
different links in the box
do so much oh yeah there problem you can
come check us out on patreon we got tons
of exclusives and goodies over there
come join our community have a good time
we also got t-shirts available on
Spreadshirt thank you for checking this
video out peace